people just like watching things fall
for some reason it's almost hypnotizing
my name is Lily Heba Sh
and I'm a domino artist which means I
set up thousands of dominoes and
intricate arrangements and patterns and
then I knock them down Lily is the most
popular Domino artist on YouTube with 2
million subscribers and half a billion
views but not everybody gets I get a lot
of comments on YouTube
someone will be like don't want to
that's not an art form anyone can do
that they don't understand what goes
into a domino setup behind every
successful project is a lot of
painstaking work over the past decade
she spent thousands of hours building
projects like these elaborate Domino
chains that have made fans out of
celebrities set multiple records and
earned her a massive online following
but even with all that experience each
project carries the same risk you know
it's gonna knock down at some points and
you just have to learn how to deal with
that and get past it and keep rebuilding
keep doing it even if it fails she calls
her favorite project the amazing triple
spiral it took 8 days and $15,000 to set
up Lilly also works on teams she was one
of two leads on this massive setup which
took 19 builders 250,000 dominoes in a
full week to construct from start to
finish it fell for an astonishing 12
minutes and 39 seconds and broke three
records including largest overall Domino
projects in America when I'm building
it's like I'm almost in a trance and I
like get into the zone of where I could
just focus on the Domino's and create
something that I think of and make it
come to life some people are like very
square and geometric if it are lines I'm
kind of like freeform and I like go all
over the place with my setups and I
think that's why people like it because
they can always be surprised by what's
gonna come next and dominoes aren't the
only ingredient she also mixes in Rube
Goldberg like tricks which allow even
more opportunities to think in three
dimensions to start a project Lily first
decides which elements to build around
so there's a lot of names for different
tricks the most standard ones are the
Domino line Domino curve a domino field
power wall pyramid there's a lot of
tricks I do all the structures first so
that's like the walls the towers and in
case one of those towers falls by
accident it won't knock down or that
other things are rounded and then after
I do all the structures I do all the
flat projects which is the fields the
lines the turns this is a direction
changer so when the clear Domino hits
the top of it it'll spin and then it'll
hit the yellow one and make it go and in
angle and then I connect it all with a
single Domino line I think the main
thing is just being calm and precise so
there are two main ways for a project to
fail one is if the chain gets stuck and
doesn't fall all the way through and one
tape and then of course there are
accidental Falls
yeah I'm not gone by accident a couple
of times as a dominant builder you have
to learn to get through fails and just
try to figure out what failed how to
improve it and get better to avoid
accidental knock downs
she uses a fail-safe technique as I'm
building I make safety gaps by taking
out like five Domino's here and there
and if I knock it down my accident it'll
stop at that gap so it doesn't knock
down the whole thing got to be super
super careful and especially because I'm
like in this setup right now filling in
safety gaps is probably the most
stressful part of it because if you
knock it down it could knock down the
whole thing so it's pretty tense after
her first viral video in 2013 it became
clear that this is no longer just a
hobby Domino is my full-time job
currently right now I'm traveling around
the world doing these projects for
companies who want their logo done in
Domino's I've done commercials and
different things for ad agencies to
recreate images from pop culture or
logos like this she starts on her
computer so when I do a picture out of
dominoes first I'll find the image
online and then there's a computer
program on Microsoft Excel where you put
the image that you found online
beneath the cells and it'll actually
convert the cells into a Domino pixel
then she prints out a step-by-step guide
on how to recreate the image in Domino
form so it'll say like Row 1 3 white for
black and then you know exactly how many
Domino's to actually make
and then I set up cameras and I knock it
down
Lily posts a new video every Saturday it
takes up so much of her time that she's
actually decided to take a break from
college to focus on her career my
youtube channel is doing so well I'm
getting a lot of inquiries I'm able to
sustain myself and I don't really need a
degree to do what I'm doing if I want to
go back to college in the future I can
that's always an option but I already
have the job that I want the best part
for me is seeing something that I work
so hard on worth all the way through
after sometimes even spending weeks
planning and building it I finally get
to see the payoff when I knock it down
and when I see that laughs I'm gonna
fall that's like the best part like
that's what I live for